esse é o meu trabalho tem muito a ver
com com a palestra anterior eu de
natureza só um amante da natureza e como
um palestrante interior como biólogo
estudou mais os animais e as plantas
então vendo aqui eu nasci no nos andes
peruanos mas minha mãe era de origem
amazônica a típica de um grupo nativa
muito importante para a amazónia e
embaraçam isso minha mãe quando conheceu
meu pai e ambos cuidavam de flores e
plantas medicinais e o comércio e outras
67 anos eu trabalhei é uma banca fazendo
isso então mais tarde com um azarado o
passar dos anos a criança durante na
escola tem um intervalo na hora de
brincar eo meu trabalho e nesse período
era brincar com as plantas no jardim da
escola
então para mim era pra ser o suíço está
pulando brincando com isto é uma
representação de eu sei é o número de m
me sorte porque eu nascer 26 e eu me
lembro quando criança que o presente e
não só de crianças até de agora o
presente maior que 6 1 mas a alegria foi
uma uma tesoura de poda
sempre quis ter daniel foi o dia mais
feliz
essa convivência com a as plantas a
natureza por exemplo o hortelã e água e
não é uma das plantas que a convivência
é muito pequeno todo mundo sabe que se
reparar
gaspar a mesmas para tirar a ansiedade e
dormir melhor e paralelo a isso alguns
rituais indígenas por exemplo naquele
tempo não tinha os aparelhos que hoje
nós temos para detectar a doença ea
localização e um dos pré nativos dos
andes era utilizado como um sensor tal
eles o curandeiro tinha habilidade
segurar o preá com as pernas esticadas e
o peito nu e ele podia através de passar
pelo corpo poderia detectar a
localização do problema por causa da
diferença de temperatura então onde o
problema estava presente ele reagir
dessa maneira a gente por indicar onde
estava localizado o problema e aí pra
frente o tratamento
botamos para idade a criança então eu
disse bom que minha profissão bom eu
quero estudar as plantas o que tem
onde tem quanto tem e identifiquei que
minha profecia minha vocação seria
violou então a partir daí não comecei
esse caminho
isto é na universidade no litoral ea
primeira vontade que eu tinha quando
termina a facultar a votar tomazoni
foi o que eu fiz e até eu fiz a gravação
eu fiz o mestrado ea partir daí comecei
a estudar os tipos de alguns tipos de
solo tipo de vegetação e tudo o que
tinha lá dentro não
então você vê os diferentes tipologias
de vegetação e cada tipologia de
vegetação como deus é maravilhoso de um
pouco não dispensa diferentes com
propriedades para alguma coisa então foi
aí que partimos para o trabalho em si
por um lado o trabalho de campo dias no
time se na mata no inventariando
pesquisando as plantas e coletando para
depositar nos ser vários então a partir
aí também a convivência com as pessoas
que vivem na margem do rio não na beira
da estrada nas comunidades sobre os us
dessas plantas para a tratar seus
problemas de saúde
então foi foi adquirindo uma um
conhecimento
donde unia o conhecimento tradicional e
também o conhecimento científico que a
era feito ao longo do tempo a partir daí
a partir daí começamos saber de que
algumas plantas se apropriar disso outra
será folclore e um exemplo grande por
exemplo a unha de gato
essa é a verdadeira e aquele a fase não
então começou aí
era triste quando você vê que uma planta
eletro uma coisa você toma usa e não
funciona e está também tem essa
descoberta está aí e eu nunca pensei
mesmo é ser médico mas como eu sabia que
planta e onde tem quanto têm e para que
serve
acabei virando um curandeiro não então
acabei virando um terapeuta hoje
trabalho como isso não como uma
profissão porque o trabalho ainda no
inpa com o pesquisador
mas foi muito importante porque é esse
conhecimento fez que no inpa por exemplo
quando alguém tinha um problema de saúde
e não era recebido por movimento do
convencional
as pessoas se é na feira o ângulo
curioso alguém que podia orientá-los
para essa cura e é no impacto claro no
tempo que os comem e convencê lá tenha
mais de 50 botânicos e hoje não somos
oito para você ver como a evolução
científica muito muito não
então a comandar 50 pesquisadores em
botânica bom ou não davam palpite eu
tomava nome é uma reunião de votar nem
consegui disse olha por favor quando
alguém queira
sobre o uso de alguma planta mãe para
mim que eu posso ajudar melhor e aqueça
área que eu consigo mexer melhor
então esse nível muito para o site
também te dar essa solução pelo menos há
para o conhecimento actual vamos ver se
é assim então ó a partir daí eu fui como
disse assim foi entrando no campo do
terapeuta
depois de tantos anos de trabalho e só
uma parte das plantas num então você
tinha uma planta para desinflamar outra
para vamos ver se a ajudar no sistema
nervoso então você tinha esta você tinha
para baixar a glicose tinha esta quando
estávamos assim com fraqueza no corpo
você tinha esta que no caso jatobá e
assim uma série de plantas que a gente
possa inaugurar e numerar e você tinha
uma grande número de plantas e essas
plantas eram apresentadas de uma outra
maneira por exemplo unha de gato
aqui esse aqui a planta cunha da linha
de gatton não
então hoje em dia há como disse a
senhora sinal de meio de medicamentos
que você tem é é bastante pequeno em
relação ao que poderia ter você tem
pintura você tem dinheiro você tem um o
próprio olho
e você tem essa diversidade à disposição
então através dessa desse trabalho é
terapeuta ea orientação a gente tem
contribuído muito para ajudá lo a
combater essas matérias nas células que
hoje em dia existe enquanto se refere à
saúde não aqui então eu pensei bom assim
como eu conheço há muito têm o
conhecimento desse potencial de plantas
eu tinha escrevo este e outros livros eu
determinei que assim como eu tinha
aprendido não através de esse trabalho e
eu disse bom eu também posso ensinar
eu posso ensinar de que maneira e eu vou
à hipocampo então faz dez anos gelaria
pesquisa não incluiu me perdi o cargo de
professor porque quim pública não se
manter como fez como o professor que não
pública não vale mais nada pra mim não
me importou porque meu objetivo não era
tanto ser professor e cinco com poder
contribuir
você já imagina alguém escrever um livro
sobre alguma coisa e isso na prática não
dá certo não então não tem sentido e eu
disse não a partir de 2000 e pouco 2002
eu disse não agora eu vou pro campo vou
mostrar que isso é possível e que só vai
dar certo
então eu sair de manaus foi manaquiri um
município a 140 quilômetros de manaus
muito bem então nós criamos um centro de
treinamento de produtores rurais em
negócios sustentáveis em manaquiri que
que precisávamos fazer a lava
primeiro o ribeirinhos os que vivem nas
beiras das estradas dos municípios
eles não sabem a riqueza que eles têm
não alguém precisava ensinar a eles que
será possível também eles precisavam
saber que esse conhecimento que eles têm
poderia ser transformado em uma fonte de
renda não então através da retirada
vamos ver se por exemplo o time amarelo
a kaká o chez chama o chá amarelo porque
o fruto não é comestível e se chama o
chá amarelo porque de cor amarelo
mas a parte utilizada como terapêutico é
a casca e eles nunca é podíamos não
sabia
então quando foram ensinados para eles
eles começaram a utilizar o que vocês
têm uma idéia que hoje em dia o
conhecimento sobre problemas vamos
decidir do aparelho reprodutor feminino
não existem medicamentos por exemplo não
estamos falando no mercado regional no
mercado mundial em do metrô 11s cistos
nos ovários micropolicísticos assim
nódulo no seio
câncer no colo do útero câncer na
próstata
é um problema de saúde é muito
importante e de repente você tem essa
planta que chama oxi que cuida dos
distúrbios hormonais e você tem esta que
tira as dores e vai fortalecendo a
imunidade então você tem a mais ver
resolve não mais tarde você tem abcd
pois a resolver outra doença e assim não
chegaram
imaginem a letra a letra l e 78 e com
isso construir palavras essas plantas
que vocês vêem aqui pode construir
formulasse que podem ter a cura moderna
então esse conhecimento que a gente está
apresentando aqui é muito importante
para esse futuro
então aqui você tem manaquiri você tem
por exemplo a capacitação de jovens de
todas as idades se no centro
nós temos o trabalho de campo na
colheita por exemplo isso aqui que vocês
vêem aqui é exatamente esta que sirva
para o tratamento de gastrites naquele
lado que você vem aquele monte de
sementes em handlova e andiroba e
assista aqui em forma de óleo
não então o centro de treinamento tem
essa função
essa função conhecimento popular
pesquisa produto e principalmente a
mudança de vida com a geração de de
renda não
então esse nosso trabalho é um trabalho
vamos dizer assim é pequeno mas sem
muito importante porque não só pode
ajudar nessa na geração de renda ea
conservação da floresta mas também pode
ajudar na jogar com o mundo
os medicamentos que podem resolver esse
mundo bártoli então destruir a floresta
aumento da doença solução cortar a
floresta que a floresta tenha cura
obrigado